erasmus+ meet Theo Rasmussen later meet
Theo Rasmussen kamila is a teacher she's
just returned from a job shadowing
placement in Germany with Erasmus plus
the school she visited is pioneering
effective ways to engage pupils from
disadvantaged backgrounds carmella can't
wait to tell her head teacher and other
colleagues about what she learned Manolo
is Spanish he met carmella
on his Erasmus year at Roskilde
University a global law firm took him on
after he graduated and he's been in
Denmark ever since ah still in love
after all those years he later mum Elena
is off on a youth volunteering placement
in Italy she'll be helping older people
learning computer skills good experience
for next year when she'll be a college
training as a software engineer
Paden became good friends with Marik
when he was on a European work placement
in Poland Adam now has more
international connections than he can
count and thanks to his international
experience with a green energy firm a
local renewables company will hire Adam
as an apprentice once he's passed his
exams
erasmus+ isn't just for erasmus ins ask
your youth organization school college
or university to help you to experience
erasmus+ if you'd like to find out more
visit ECE europa dot EU forward slash
erasmus - + more join the conversation
on social media